it's just past 1300 GMT 2 pm in Morocco
where a powerful earthquake has killed
more than a thousand people and injured
hundreds more officials are reporting
significant and widespread damage across
several regions the number of dead is
expected to rise well this was the
moment the magnitude 6.8 Tremors struck
late on Friday evening as you can see it
sent people running for their lives the
Tremors struck some 70 kilometers south
of the popular tourist city of Marrakech
for the shocks were felt as far away as
the coastal cities of Robert Casablanca
and esuera it's the worst disaster
Morocco has seen in more than 20 years
hashimatabara begins our coverage
hours after a powerful earthquake struck
Morocco the scale of widespread
Devastation is now emerging flattened
houses and streets that resemble a war
zone Marrakesh is the closest major city
to the epicenter of the quake
rescue workers who have worked through
the night continue to look for people
trapped under the rubble
but there are several areas still Out Of
Reach and people are desperate
the roads are
clear we can't drive we need help to get
people from under the rubble
my parents are home it is necessary to
get help we cannot continue without
water or electricity the roads are
blocked we only wanted to get our
parents out of the house but we could
not
it began a little past 11 pm local time
on Friday night when many Moroccans were
out this is the moment when the
earthquake struck sending panics
tricking people out on the streets many
others were jolted from their sleep
piles of debris from flattened houses
and collapsed buildings lined what were
once residential areas
the desperate search for loved ones
began soon after
a video posted online shows a mother
trying to reach her children stuck under
the rubble the number of dead is rising
we dispatch a number of security teams
at rescue operation to various affected
areas we urge all citizens to stay calm
the interior ministry will update the
public later
the U.S Geological Survey says the
epicenter was in the Atlas Mountains
some 70 kilometers Southwest of
Marrakesh
there are reports of damage in
marrakesh's Old Town a U.N world
heritage site
the Quake was also felt as far away as
the coastal cities of babat Casablanca
and the sawyera and many people spent
the night out on the streets
the house rocked aggressively everyone
was scared and I was shocked I didn't
understand what was happening I thought
it was only my house that was moving
because it's fragile and old I heard
people screaming everyone went out of
their houses to the streets which were
full of people and women screaming
hospitals in Marrakesh are creating
hundreds of injured people now many are
worried about the risk of aftershocks in
the coming days and weeks al-jazeera
joins us now live on set and Hashem the
focus now on these particular hours they
are the hours that make the difference
between life and death right the island
this explains why we're getting this
numbers now uh climbing to more than a
thousand victims of the earthquake
talking about also dozens of people uh
critically injured so these are
assumedly people going through the
rubble and finding their loved ones
sadly alive exactly and we are yet to
get a sense of what happened in Ariel
which is the epicenter of the earthquake
this is one of the villages that were
massively affected by the earthquake
along with issue and many other areas in
the in the Atlas Mountains it will take
the government some time to be able to
get a complete picture of what happened
and I think this explains why we're
getting these numbers further increasing
the authorities are saying that the Army
has been employed with specialized units
to try to
rescue those traps under the rubber it's
going to be extremely extremely
difficult situation I think the who was
saying that something like 300 000
people could have been impacted by this
do we have any idea how many of that
number might be still trapped under the
rubble you see this is the thing because
we're talking about villagers to be able
to drive to those Villages I myself
drive to those Villages and it takes me
sometimes seven hours to drive just for
35 kilometers very rough terrain very
extremely difficult to get access to and
there are thousands and thousands of
local community people living in local
communities in this desolate mountainous
areas
and this is the concern the concern is
is how many people are still trapped
under the the Wobble and how many
buildings have been severely compromised
because of this earthquake and if I can
add to that what happens to the people
who survive this now you and I will
remember when we covered the devastating
earthquakes in turkia in February one of
the early the challenges that we faced
and many people faced in the disaster
was basic things like finding water
this is Winter the beginning of a rainy
season in uh Morocco the Army is saying
that it has set up the first makeshift
Hospital in the area the challenge will
be to set up makeshift tent in those
areas or move people to uh temporary
shelters we have to wait and see the
number of people affected in those areas
if we're talking about thousands then
the authorities will definitely have to
set up immediate tents in those areas to
cope with the growing number of the
people displaced because of the
earthquake and this explains why the
authorities are appearing on people for
Crime saying that they are doing their
best to try to cope with the magnitude
of this earthquake
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much
is Professor of earth science and
engineering at King Abdullah University
in Saudi Arabia joins us from jedic good
to have you with us so first of all take
us through how frequent how prone is
this area to earthquakes
well um thank you good afternoon first
first of all I'd like to express my
condolences and and deep grief to the
people of Morocco and all those who who
have been affected
um listening to the stories and seeing
the videos is this just disheartening
um
you know this this area is not unknown
to experience earthquakes it had
earthquakes in the 1960s and uh in the
uh early let's say 19th century
they are infrequent
um but they do occur and we from a
scientific point of view know the
earthquake has it in this region exists
as documented by these previous
earthquakes and their damage and
fatalities that these earthquakes had
um created so it's not entirely unknown
or uncommon to experience earthquakes
there
how much of a threat are after shocks
and for how long are they a threat to
people who might be you know wondering
can they go back indoors can they if
they still have houses left can they is
it safe for them to go home
yeah that's an excellent question in
fact
um in particular if slightly damaged
houses are you know experienced just a
little bit additional shaking from
aftershocks they might just uh fall down
at that point
um so from seismological let's say
experience and statistical work we know
that
aftershocks of magnitude five to five
and a half are likely to occur after
this earthquake of magnitude 6.8 so
these are strong events strong Quakes
that you know create substantial shaking
um and these aftershocks will continue
for several weeks
and and so it's not uncommon to see even
a magnitude 5 earthquake I'm I'm
speculating say in a month or two as a
you know as the Earth
let's say response to the strong shaking
it
experienced and what we call the changes
in stress on on the fault that caused
this earthquake you mentioned the
earthquakes of the 60s have lessons been
learned as far as you can tell from
those earthquakes in terms of
construction codes and how life goes on
um yeah excellent question again um I
have to admit I I don't really know I've
traveled myself in this area in this
very area that's now affected
um a few years ago and in my observation
on on the buildings I saw the building
style the classical construction style
there is that it follows the traditional
um
um pattern so a mud break adobe brick
boat buildings not reinforced not
necessarily concrete and I think in one
of the um
um
interviews earlier with one of the
victims who said that his house is
fragile I believe this is is very much
true for many of the Village Housing and
even in the medieval cities like
Marrakesh very intensely populated very
densely built
um but to standards that's the
traditional
um architecture mostly so I don't think
but I don't know for sure I don't think
this is really built according to
seismic safe standards and looking at it
from a seismic perspective does this
earthquake change the risk assessment
for the region
um it will
um first of all if if now scientists
take this information uh from this
earthquake where precisely it occurred
how it occurred and also examine what
shaking levels were experienced we can
use that information to update or
improve what we call the earthquake
hazard Maps and because they rely
critically on information of past events
like this one
um while we update like the scientific
and engineering community updates these
Hazard Maps it is actually critical
um to address the question you asked
namely how safe are our buildings is our
building code
um still sufficient and if it is
sufficient is it enforced so there's
always this let me say human component
to to Natural hazards that
we cannot predict earthquakes we cannot
prevent earthquakes the only thing we
can do is to prepare for earthquakes
and so that's now a subsequent question
that needs to be asked
all right
yes let's hope so thanks so much for
your analysis on that Martin Mai